the meantime bars around the valley that
do not serve food well they are still
closed they've been closed for weeks now
there's now a lawsuit though between bar
owners and the state to lift governor
steve siselek's order to stay closed
the judge overseeing that case could
make a ruling here very soon
steiner's pub in the northwest valley
one of the plaintiffs in that case
and kate houston is there live now with
the latest hi kate
hi alex yes district judge carrie early
is
now looking into whether or not she has
the authority to lift this
order in the meantime many bars around
the area are struggling to stay afloat
behind me we have an individual who has
a sign who
is upset with the governor's directive
now she is not alone
this lawsuit was filed last month just a
few days after governor sislek
ordered bars to close since then the
governor has changed the criteria for
closures
opting for more localized enforcement
today i spoke to randy miller who owned
several taverns in las vegas
including miller's tavern and sun city
summerlin that's one of
37 bars listed on the lawsuit he says
the reason for the lawsuit is simple
they don't want to be singled out in
this blanket closure without any
evidence
we've had hundreds of inspections and we
complied
a hundred percent with the governor's
directive we know the governor's in a
difficult spot
but even by his own admission he stated
that
maybe this wasn't the fairest way to do
it well that's all well and good but
we're still closed
randy tells me many bars have remained
closed and
employees are still struggling to get
unemployment now we're back outside
steiner's pub as you can see behind me
this sign that this woman
is holding saying shame on you governor
sislek they are awaiting
a directive a decision on this
directive and that could be happening
very soon now the attorney representing
the state of nevada
says there is no precedent for the court
to act in this case
kate houston 8 news now all right kate
thanks for that update